Hello. Welcome to Michael's Better Business English.
This month, we're looking at how to be an active listener.
Now, this is very important for Japanese business people.
Often, Japanese people, when listening, go into "silent mode".
Saying nothing, no reaction.
It is very difficult to have a conversation with them.
Instead, you should be using these active listening techniques.
Three - kick techniques.
First, show interest.
This is by using expressions like, "really", "interesting".
This encourages the speaker...
...and supports them.
Makes it easier for them to keep speaking.
Second, check understanding.
If you are not sure, say something.
"So, what do you mean by...", "Sorry, I didn't understand this."
By being active and checking understanding, you can ensure effective conversation.
And third, develop the conversation.
"Develop the conversation" means extend or expand the conversation into other areas.
For example, "Oh, your trip to Germany sounds interesting."
"Have you been to other European countries?..."
...or, "That project sounds very exciting,..."
"...can you tell me more about it?"
So, this is expanding and extending the conversation further.
Finally, remember the image of tennis.
Good listener in a conversation is like playing a game of tennis.
They're helping to keep the ball in the air.
By being an active listener, you can do this.
Thank you and good luck!